Marco Rubio tweeted I don't want
actually you know I'm going to play I'm
going to play his video statement
instead just we'll just we'll just
listen to what he has to say one of the
most important things President Biden
needs to make clear tonight is that if
US troops us diplomats us Personnel in
the Middle East come under attack by
these Iranian backed and controlled Shia
militia groups in the region if they
attack our people we are going to
consider that to be attack by the
government of Iran against the United
States that will require an extensive uh
response an exensive retaliatory
response just in the last 24 hours we've
seen an uptick in attacks by these
groups against a military forces and
there are troubling indicators that
that's going to turn into a full-scale
campaign and we can't allow it it is
important the president make it
abundantly clear by laying out clear and
credible red lines that if Iran crosses
will require us to engage them I don't
want there to be a Middle East War I
don't want the US involved in another
Middle East War but if Iran through its
proxies decide to attack us we're going
to have to retaliate and it's important
in order to prevent this for the
president to make that clear tonight
what he basically said is if anyone
attacks our troops we can just claim it
was Iran and then declare war well they
never declare war just send troops go uh
to go and invade Iran we already know
that our troops have been attacked with
these drone attacks that news uh came
out a little while ago we have Biden
publishing the faces of a special forces
uh group uhoh so how close are we to a
troop getting hurt or attacked which he
says they're already upping and then
Lindsey Graham Marco Rubio have already
basically said war war war with Iran I
think it should be mandatory any
politician who calls for this should be
air dropped there first mandatory right
away you go first Marco Rubio you go
first lindsy Graham yeah you go first I
agree it should be mandatory you want to
call for war then you have to go serve
why is that radical well no no they're
just too important they're too important
they're not that important you know
they're too important we can't air drop
them into the places they want to B
people work remotely all the time surely
they can call in well we'll have a vote
we'll have a vote we'll have the people
of South Carolina vote should Lindsey
Graham who advocated for war with Iran
be sent to Iran to help coordinate and
lead the charge overwhelmingly people
would say yes if you said it should be
mandated they go to war because
Democrats are so proud of their vote for
Joe Biden and they support him even now
to this day we should also you know when
we're doing the draft and we're saying
who should go to war I think the Joe
Biden supporters that voted for him they
should be at the front of the list yeah
they should yeah I think that makes
sense too I think that's a great idea
you vote for war go fight it do we send
Joe Biden to war yes as a general I
really feel like his commands would be
interesting but to be fair I think we
should give him one of those those exo
suits they've been working on you ever
you see those ones where it's like you
can lift stuff with it yep at least then
he can move around it'll be nimble
Honestly though I I would wear the exo
suit I think it's pretty cool it reminds
me of uh sigy Weaver when she's
I'm see now if Jo Biden made a video of
him in one of his machines fighting
against like enemies of the United
States he'd probably get a lot of people
to enlist yeah yeah true that would be
more power I'm your president now I'm
going to war and then he's
like jumps
20t if he really did that if he really
did that I would
probably you convinced me can I get one
of those suits yeah that's the most
important thing if I get a suit I'm
there but they're not going to tell you
that you've already gone through stuff
they'll they'll they'll string you along
that's how military if you get Luhan to
do it enlistment will just be 100%
that's true Lan biggest s up ever she's
awesome who Luhan the really hot girl oh
right right right
right personal when she said that but
she was like posting she was like a
scops A or officer she's doing a great
job she makes me want to win list to be
honest I don't know if I'm thinking of
the same person but there was like this
woman who was saying she was in the
military and kept posting all these
things about why people should join or
whatever ever have you seen Luhan do you
know who I'm talking I don't I don't
know what Luhan is all you have to do is
look up Luhan she's all over Tik Tok
she's got like a million on Tik Tok that
I might be she the best ever uh l u j a
an
Luhan yeah yeah of course yeah yeah I've
totally seen this yeah she's amazing
yeah she's she's actually in the Army
though isn't she yeah she's a scops
think they they specifically bring in
these young hot girls to convince men to
go die yep like dude you're not going
any near this person this person is not
real like this is this is this just
we'll get one we'll get her in one of
those exo suits yeah this is just Pinups
version her and Joe Biden suddenly
recruitment I bet she's convinced a
bunch of really dumb young guys to sign
up oh yeah oh yeah and she's massive on
Tik Tok too she's got like a million on
Tik Tok yep there's one that I saw of
like not her but two other like
good-looking girls being like the best
part at being in the Army is being a
barracks buunny and then this guy like
Cuts Like no no that's that's not true
that's Hing like that's yeah she posted
which basically is like she will have
sex with you yeah if you it's like the
old beer commercials yep if you drink
our beer hot women will have sex with
you that's a Family Guy joke by the way
I'm stealing it but yeah yep but this is
what they're doing subtly subtly she got
a million followers but I'm saying like
the ones that are saying like I paid for
by the US Army are the ones that are
much more about like wokeism like is she
criticizing CNN I couldn't tell what
that she a bit conserv I think she did a
few videos with like donut operator and
the Black Rifle guys oh really oh really
I didn't know that but I I mean like the
assumption is her her her job in the
Army is to post these videos to convince
people to enlist it's like a thirst trap
for Frontline troops which is incredible
man like imagine being dumb Canon cannon
fodder for these sick corrupt
individuals yeah man like I said natural
selection I guess filter them out huh is
that what it is it could be man if I if
I get one of those suits I'm there like
I said they can promise you that I mean
they're going to have to do something
soon right there there's a report out
today that um one of the re one of the
major reasons people can't elist is
because obesity is so high I
mean we're impending on war faster than
we can solve the problems that we have
created that make it difficult for
people to join the military and by that
I mean they don't qualify to join the
military and um other than lowering the
standards which is not really good for a
military fighting population I'm not
sure how we get past this issue um the
fact of the matter is you know and I I'm
a broken record here I know anyone who's
heard me on the show before has heard me
say this but the statistics bear out
that there's a very slim majority of
people or slim margin of people that can
make the standards to enlist in the
military and of those people very few of
them are willing to do it so you know
great for her that she has a million Tik
Tok followers on the other hand she is
not she doesn't have a 100% success rate
because we are not converting that many
people into military recruitment true
yeah it's down true true yeah I think
it's the low they've had like the lowest
recruitment what like 14 years or
something almost every Branch very few
branches are making their recruitment
goals uh this is something that's been
happening consistently for the past at
least three years probably longer and in
fact military enlistment has been down
for a long time I mean to be fair you
know I've mentioned my brother was in
the Marine Corps he went to he deployed
to Afghanistan the thing is like he was
I I don't remember how old he was he was
very young when we got invol involved in
that there were people who went after
him who were not alive when everything
broke out in the Middle East this is
going to be the reality for Gen Z
they're going to be this generation that
is saying are we about to enter a war
that we will be in endlessly on multiple
fronts and the messaging around it will
always be ambiguous it'll be unclear
what our actual goals are and I think
that's that's definitely the case uh now
that we have war in Ukraine we have
conflict in in Israel and then
presumably we're going to have something
happen in Taiwan I mean do you want to
be deployed FL do you want to go into
active conflict like this well and your
body will not be your choice because
they have forced vaccinations in the
military so uh they got they got well
yes they've always had that though well
but the co shot as well that will but I
mean like but this is like the the
interesting thing to me I mean when you
when you sign up they give you a bunch
of injections you don't even know what
you're getting yeah true the story I
what I was told by my friends is that
you know you're in basic training that's
like you you walk down a line and then
give you a shot and then you walk down
you get a shot and then you walk down
then give a shot and like they're giving
you all your yeah yeah because it
doesn't I mean the thing is you could
probably read through the recruitment
paperwork and I'd be happy for anyone to
correct me on this and they might say
you're going to get these vaccines right
right but the thing is once you sign up
you agree to go through them because
that is part of making this
qualification goal that you you submit
to the vaccines that you submit to
certain things is it is it true that
when you enlist your government property
I mean effectively right something like
that like if you get injured rock
climbing they consider damage to
government property or something like
that it's why like if you uh are in the
military and you get pneumonia while
you're skiing right people will pay out
of pocket because it can affect
everything that has St to do with your
job I mean your physical body and your
Wellness are something that they take
priority on it's why you know you'll get
military guys who pay out of pocket so
that they don't have to report certain
issues or illnesses or injuries I got I
got to be honest when I look at this uh
Luhan chck I see she she's working she
still working it's the opposite these
photos make me think the military is
trash the Army is garbage that people
who are serving are losers like how many
how many young men enlisted because of
something as stupid as this how dumb do
you have to be for this to be the reason
now the people who are like after 911 I
enlisted I'm like wow those people are
those people are tough that's crazy but
now like this is what it is you got the
weird wokeness and thirst traps dude is
that what you're doing she's bringing
Tik Tok influencers into the recruiting
offices I'm not kidding she's like doing
videos with these Tik Tok influencers in
the recruiting offices that's how stupid
it is I just for me personally and maybe
it's CU I'm an old man but this gives
makes me feel disdained for the AR for
for the institution of the Armed Forces
not for the soldiers who sign up for
good reasons but like I'm saying like 10
20 years if this is what we have to
represent the
Army good luck I guess be I kind of feel
like the reason recruitments is low is
because they're doing this yeah I agree
look I talked about this earlier
Victoria Secret announced they're
getting rid of their woke morbidly obese
and gross uh uh models about time you
know they have like they're not all
nasty looking like but like you know
have people like Megan rapo right and
why would a woman want to buy sexy
underwear is it because she wants to be
a world champion soccer player I really
don't think so I think it's because she
wants to attract men I'm not saying
every woman wants to attract men I'm not
saying every woman's goal and only goal
is to attract men I'm saying the purpose
of attract RVE underwear is to be
attractive right yeah so women are
buying fancy underwear just like look in
the mirror and be like look me I'm good
do yeah cute underwear and what makes
you think but I would agree with your
general premise like lingerie and the
the base product of Victoria Secret
would be for the attra being attractive
to and so it is fair to say a lot people
often say that women don't wear makeup
for men they wear makeup for other women
and that's and but so here this is the
point when women look at Victoria secret
they want to see an objectively
attractive woman and they want to
emulate that so they can feel like they
are also like that woman they are
objectively attractive when you put
morbidly obese women and ugly women in
your ads women are like I don't want to
look like that that women's gross and so
what happened Victoria Secret Sales
started dropping they dropped like like
10% or no no I'm sorry like one what is
it went from like 7.5 to like 6.5% or
whatever or 6.2 or something sales d
dropped and so now they're abandoning
this campaign and they're going back to
the angels this is the same thing I see
you have that Russian military
commercial where it's the dude and he's
like doing push-ups and he jumps out of
a plane and then he lands and he's like
imagine the male power fantasy it ain't
looking at some dainty female and being
like I I see this and I'm like I kind of
feel like the people that are going to
be attracted to the military are like
you know very girly effeminate boys who
want to put on fox ears and emulate that
that's who they tracked if they had like
some super ripped dude punching through
a brick wall like I just watched all
four Expendables movies I'm like this is
what men watch apparently like not
literally but look at Die Hard look at
look at these movies where like yippi
Kaye and he pulls the gun out and he
shoots the bad guy that's not this so
they're like maybe we can attract stupid
young men because they want to have sex
with girls yeah I mean probably yeah
young men are having less sex than ever
but then I throw it to the Victoria
Secret angle that when men are thinking
about a
most men are probably not like man I
really want to be what what does a man
want to be when he sees this when you
when you put the commercial the Marines
had a commercial where uh when everyone
was ragging on the Army because they had
that I have two moms and they were like
why is the Army doing this the Marines
had a commercial where a guy like Rises
up out of the swamp with like you know
paint on his face and a rifle and starts
moving forward and it was much
tougher that's the adventure guys are
seeking that they're feeling like a call
to action a purpose mhm this is not that
well the Marines in particular have
consistently made the recruitment goals
because you know they are selling much
more of a fraternity of of this very
Enclave Niche there is a culture not
that other branches don't but the uni
the Marines is sort of know I mean what
is that movie Full Metal Jacket people
are sort of aware of what comes with
being a marine there's an inherent
toughness it's the same reason that
they're able to make recruitment goals
for things like Green Berets or Navy
Seals is because those are sort of these
aspirations
and these Elite positions that men are
driven to seek out I don't think that
these tactics are serving a purpose
because in some ways they're
directionless they're not capitalizing
on who is actually looking to have a
place in the military what I what I what
we people super chated us this last time
that when we are talking about the the
Army commercial where it's like I have
two moms and I'm in the Army and then
the Marines commercial is like I'm a
marine and they were like it's because
the Army is very administrative like
they don't they don't care if they
attract a bunch of like effeminate loser
guys with no self-esteem because they're
going to make you type on a computer or
something you people on the desks
otherwise stuff doesn't work yeah but
that's just sad but that maybe means
Army is too big you know like is that
just saying essentially they have too
many administrators to function
correctly I mean what are we actually
doing because ultimately we do pay for
the service
members yeah we the
taxpayers look somebody changing too you
know it's like it's like you know you
watch those old movies about like the
night and he has The Squire and The
Squire has to like pick up the horse's
crap and just do all the really awful
stuff like someone's got to do that you
know so if you want to be that then you
can go hang out with this chick and be
the person who picks up the crap for the
for the actual Heroes and the and the
manly men who are in the Marines and
special forces and stuff like that there
you go maybe there's a place for
everybody in the
military I don't mean that literally
though right I know that people there's
there's a lot of good people in the Army
who sent it for good reasons I'm just
really disgusted by the attempted to to
like this is their recruit like this is
the manipulation like H it's just I find
but like I said this is the influencer
who's on social media as like a third
platform but on mainstream media if you
look at TV commercials it's not this
they're exactly so they're trying to
play both fields and both Fields that's
the same thing see I feel like it's just
two different sides of the same Corin
but like they are not sticking to oh I
have two moms and I'm feminist and
whatever else they're bringing out this
girl Alpha strong arrogant whatever you
want to call them guys are not going
like oh I bet you'll date me if I enlist
they're going like true they're going I
want want to do more pull-ups I want to
I want to be something greater than
myself I want to go on that mission I
want to save the world yeah the same
people who are looking at the if2 moms
these are the male feminists who are
like I I'm I'm feminist did did I say
the right thing will you date me now
that's what that's basically what it is
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time